I always try to
make decisions based on sport, so not to
ask the question, how can
we earn the most money now,
but rather what serves the game, what serves
the players and the sport,
first and foremost, investors are
welcome, they have to  just stick to the
rules of the game my goal if I leave the
DFB I leave the ship then
I want no one to call any more [ __ ] DFB
welcome to a new
collaboration here at OMR and a
variety of premieres at once as the
first time perhaps the technical
premiere so to speak  I'm very proud
we're doing a podcast together for the first time
in this case Katrin
Gilbert and I hello
Katrin Katrin leads the conversation of the
week at the time but also has a
sports background worked at Spiegel for a long time
ALAG is a very experienced
interviewer we also know each other  from
the big stage at OMR
we have always thought for a long time that if
the right guest
appeared soon then we would like to
do a collaboration between OMR
Podcast and just the time and lo and behold
now the right guest has appeared
We had the idea together
to convince Andreas Rettig to
join this collaboration and
Andreas Rettig himself obviously has a
sports official CV that is very exciting
and for a few days I think there have been
almost 100 new changes and
that is the managing director at the DFB,
hello Andreas  Hello you two, I have to
say briefly, perhaps as housekeeping, we both have known
each other for a long time, Andreas was also
in the management at FC St Pauli for a while
and that's how
we know each other and that's why we use each other and
because it's time  This is generally the custom
and industries
and they don't know each other that well.
Katrin and Andreas will size
each other if you're wondering, okay, how can that
be, that's the background if you
should perhaps read the interview one day then it's a
you interview here the podcast but
at least my part as you so
I'll start again hello
Philip hello Ms. Gilbert no no in
Hamburg it's her and the first name ah
okay everything's clear Hamburger you have
I've already learned something again
very good  except for us Paul exactly exactly that
's exactly where St Pauli is located you exactly so
you said the first 100
days in the new office you haven't
said very much now we want to talk a
little bit about the current topics of course
there's a lot on the agenda
the hand we are now looking at the
euro year in our
own country and a lot of other things but very
briefly you once
played yourself with moderate talent
so if I have to mention that my
greatest sporting success was in the
third league at the time Oberliga Nordrhein
was the third division at the time, if the
greatest sporting success was the assist
for the goal of the month in the 80s,
which a certain klaus nüen told,
then he knows what merits I actively
earned, but at least the third division
is not bad, yes, good, so yes, yes
From your perspective, that may
be the case, but with the guys
I'm traveling with, they're
not impressed by that, yes, that's okay, yes, okay, that's true,
that's true,
but yours, your real
professional CV, so to speak, starts with the fact that you
did an apprenticeship at  Bayer
Leverkusen is in the Bayer in the
chemical company not in sports, well,
Bayer was a little more than
just chemistry, so it's also pharmaceuticals,
it's also just a bit of
agriculture, unfortunately now,
of course, what about
Monsanto? Yes, with Monsanto
I learned the story, I'm actually a
company
child in other areas, I
went on a tour there both in the factory and
in football. My boss at the time, KI
Kalmund, took me by the hand.
I was there for almost 14 years in total, so I
also learned a decent job as a
businessman
No one will know what training to become a business assistant is like today there are
only these Masters and
Bachelors, so I'm
overwhelmed again, but that was an
empty time, there
were a few years in Pharm Sales
parallel to my active time, yes
and but it is  Dream of a lot of
young people so commitments you start
at a pharmaceutical and chemical company
and then end up in sports. How did
this change into sports come about but did I
somehow Kalm and discover it or what was
that like? I actually did back then
I was
born in Leverkusen, even though I
had no influence on where I was born at the time,
but um, so it was that I
actually applied for an apprenticeship
and was very excited
and afterwards my  Of course, my mother had given me the
best shirt and
everything you do when you
want a job, at least that's how it was back then and
then I got
a job and did training and at the
same time
I also played football and
then joined them in my youth  B 04
kicked for a year and then
Kalmund discovered me in a different
way and said okay, so um
you probably
won't become a professional footballer with your moderate talent but
with a different career how can I
maybe help you and he
kept his word and then  Are you interested then in
football? I did then. I was
very young in the first few years.
I
stopped playing actively when I was 26-27. I was then
responsible for
promoting young talent at Bayern 04 and then
became a football teacher at the same time  the sporchule in Cologne and um
I was Karlmund's assistant
so we had a great time
with today's colleague Rudi Föller,
we made great Brazil transfers,
although not with the suitcase that
came and that is always said to be the case,
but that accompanies us on our travels
But it was an incredibly great
time, very educational, yes above all,
the advantage is of course
I had nothing to decide
but was able to prepare everything freely
and of course it
took place below the level of public perception
yes that means mistakes that were made
then became the  Lucky
Kalmund is attributed to him, and although
I didn't get much praise, that sounds
like the truth,
you often hear that Kemund promoted a lot of people,
um, and
yes, he brought out talents who
later emancipated themselves, absolutely,
so I'm grateful to him, even if he did
Here and there in the last few
years we may
no longer agree quite so much on a few fundamental issues,
but I owe
him a lot, that's the
truth, and that's
why we still have a
close relationship today
Invited for a while over his 75th birthday
so
the bond lasts but as I said it was
also a hard time and
I don't want to hide that why yes because Kalii
has already someone who is demanding
no so it wasn't just
eating salads for lunch, yes  It
was like
that, you don't have any free time and my wife,
who has been with me for over 30 years,
cursed Karlmut many times, that was also part of the
story at the time and what happened
next and how did you develop from Leverkusen, so to speak
Well, the prophet is nothing in our own
country, that was the case back then and
I then went to the sports school in Cologne.
We had an outstanding
course with really great people like
Volker Fininke, Fried Funkel, Reinard
Zobel, who still knows everyone like
Hannes  Sebert keutka kgus I can
still call them all really
highly decorated expielers and this
Volker Fininke was the one who
brought me to SC Freiburg and
said man here in Freiburg we
need manager Achim Stocker, then
president, he can no longer do it
alone and you  You don't have the desire and the time,
yes, well, I had both, or at least there
was more desire. Time was then a
problem with K kalmut. By the way, that was
quite funny. I might want to
tell you that because it was actually clear that
I was a bit of the crown prince in the
house  and was also
intended as kmund's successor, no, they never told me when and then when
I told my boss
yes, I would like to change now and
no, then he said yes, okay, but three
conditions, the first condition was of course
clear, classic
succession planning, yes, so I have to  make sure
you have someone first someone is there so
I know a certain Elia,
by the way, who was still working in Switzerland at the time,
I
met him once and said man, that
could be suitable. The second thing was, um, I
had to copy my phone book at the time
So back then it was all
at hand and all the important numbers were
all in there and D he says
you have to copy it here and give it to me and
the third one shows how clever kmund
was back then and said listen and
one thing is clear when you do  If you
move from Freiburg again at some point, you have to
contractually assure us that you
will only offer your services at 04 and that
was of course an
exciting thing back then, which also caused the first
big rift in our
friendship at the time because I was
no longer from Freiburg at the time  I
wanted to go back to Leverkusen even though they
were playing in the Champions League at the time,
but I
decided to play in the second division, FC Köln, and of course that was a
bad thing for him in the worst case scenario, but why Cologne so why so
you have to in the Rhineland it's
already like that  It's a bit either
one or the other why so it
's like here St Paul in HV just said
no, just that they're in a city
where the experts say yes
Leverkusen is actually a
district of Cologne but
it was like that
A  the rivalry, the geographical proximity
of course
and
yes Leverkusen was always a bit like
that, the rich club that
of
course also did a good job by supporting the plant
but was also very
successful internationally at the time and
the FC Köln  to whom the hearts fell, who
lived by tradition, who lay
on the ground and somehow yes, it was
actually the gut and the heart that
decided, and not the wallet. When did
this feeling actually arise,
this something? Maybe you can say that
it is idealistic or morally more valuable at that time  in Freiburg
or does it come from your
youth because that was also a
traditional decision, no, absolutely, so
I'll put it like this: the older
you get, the less loudly you cry
with the wolves or you have to cry with the
wolves, so that's how it worked for me  At least
in the beginning, of course, it was
n't quite that pronounced, I'll say that
too, but I actually experienced a lot of my
more recent socialization at the
Freiburg location,
and I have to say, it was really
impressive how we have this little club
there  yes, now also with my
time, we played the Bundesliga every year
at that time, but much more important
than the promotion to the
Bundesliga at the time
was a decision like a solar system
on the roof, at the end of the 90s
we built a Freiburg football school
from the Leo Kirch millions
Everyone else had invested in the player's legs,
we
invested in stones, by the way, with
energy sources, also with a
wood chip system, so all I want to
say is that these were
topics that were already on our minds at the end of the 90s, which is
why
I actually experienced most of my
socialization  and
then the years at FC Köln then
you were promoted, so Cologne
even promoted twice, but whoever
gets promoted twice in the same
club, yes, that was a very eventful time
and I think today I do
n't know whether I'll be back at the
first FC Köln location  I think it's difficult whether you or overall whether it's
a good decision in the
city you live in, where you
have friends and everything, whether you take on responsibility in
the public job
because when you do,
stressful situations inevitably come up and so
far it has been  then always so that you
could take your little suitcase and
say now I'm going home but
my home is in Cologne and that
's of course a topic that
bothers me a lot
or at the time also of course
everything around it was a bit stressful
It's clear at this location when
not only winning and then of course
worlds collide,
I also say that with
hindsight, the happy
purelander, I'm also a carnival jock and
and and I also like to go and party
during the days  But for me, the
credo of economic reason is very
strong and there was an
incredibly heated
meeting of members and I always brought this
topic of economic reason to the
fore and that doesn't impress
the Cologne fan at all when he lost three times
so and then there was there was
a general meeting
thousands of people there and um
someone goes to the microphone and says yes man
Rettig now they're finally spending money
yes I'll calculate now what
um what it will cost us if we get relegated
no and then  I say yes, do it like that
and then yes so many millions less
sponsoring TV money that that that and
then he came up with the amount I do
n't know 20 million
and now they give it in the winter yes it was
in the autumn now they give it in the winter
Half of it from 10 million and everything
is good and to the geole and the
applause of all the members, my
then president Andreas said now
you have to say something about it too I say yes,
I'll do it Wolfgang so then I
said wi our competitors at the
time 60 Munich  cotbus and as
they are all called Bielefeld, they
all have members who are as smart
as they are and they
all do the same calculations and if
each of these competitors
invests 10 million in the winter
then no one will leave and then raw was in the
store  and then it was
raw, you didn't invest anything, no, I
didn't let myself go,
that's of course a
point. I think that's also one of the
big problems of
today, at least in my opinion. By the way, it's not an
exclusive football problem
So if responsible
or
decision-makers only understand themselves
and take responsibility in their
own short contract terms, yes then
it is a problem according to the motto
according to the flood of medicine and that can be
transferred to all areas, that is the case in
politics, so yes there are explanations
and  Promises and concepts are
developed that take off primarily to
look at how do I win the
next election and not how do I get to
better conditions in our country? The
shareholder value transmission manager of the
DAX group also looks at how he
increases his performance during his time
because he  maybe he gets a decent bonus
and the football manager rakes in
the millions in the winter because he's
saving his own ass because he
knows if we get relegated I'll be
fired anyway, so you ca
n't develop a sustainable strategy,
how often do they reach the
limits of their strategy?
This has actually happened twice in your professional life,
but I attach importance to it and
I also believe that I have
an almost unique selling point.
I have never been fired in 30 professional years
and it should
stay that way and so on  That's
why it's important for me to say
that I'm a
believer, yes, and if I
develop the feeling that it
can't go any further or that it's no
longer justifiable, then I'll just get
off the boat  but there has never been a
golden handshake, I have never
received a severance payment, I do
n't do that, that's where the biggest one comes from in your current job,
which we're talking about. Given
the
DFB's economic situation, it's
more of a
silver handshake  I
went on for a very short time in Cologne and then
how did it go on to Cologne that
was very emotional as I said I
actually
left the ship after a defeat in
Bielefeld because I said now
I also want to take responsibility,
I told him  I can't
explain a benchmark to our directors every day
and we all have to let
our performance be measured by performance and
that doesn't apply to the
sports director and that's why
I said okay with a look at the
table, then now it's time  For
me, no, and then I gave myself a
break and ultimately wanted to spend
a few months first. I
promised my wife that I wouldn't do anything, yes, and
then I somehow get a call from Walter
in Augsburg
I don't like that and yes, yes,
I really can't.
FC Augsburg was in the third league at the time.
Of course, I
quickly googled it after the
conversation and what
a successful entrepreneur he was.
Kick and Taco founder and and and  So
everything is high so really it's
really a big thing yes yes no no so
really so that I I'm just a
football manager so of course you do
n't know everyone like that and you don't at
Taco yes
exactly or something like that yes
good that was now  bad
no no so
it was like that then I said
no you don't know them and he asked me
if I could imagine
coming to Augsburg I said no
if I'm honest I'm
in Cologne right now I'm still a bit
empty  in the pear and so on and then
he says yes, I said but
you know what, call me again in three months
maybe something has
changed and somehow six weeks when
you have nothing to do and your wife is
giving up on you I have  then thought, listen,
somehow I say z to my wife,
I say K, come on, let's go to
Augsburg, is that a city we
could live in, no, and then we went there on the
weekend, we didn't know anything about it, and we
walked through the city, and it was really
great  I was totally surprised and
then thought, yes, hopefully he'll call
again, no, and at some point
the phone actually rings and
then it stopped again, yes and then
it happened very quickly and then it was
6 years for me for the longest time
Stayed with FC Augsburg, got
promoted to the Bundesliga,
built a stadium next door
and
the best thing was when I
started there. I said, okay, what
goals do you have, where do you actually want to go?
I said to be as famous as the
Augsburger Puppenkiste and I am  then
one of my first trips was
to
the Augsbrurg puppet box with the
responsible ones and
that's where the title
melody came from, so in the Augsburg
stadium an island is played at every goal,
um and yes and then we also have that too
I said funny things like that, okay, now stop with the cheese,
always handing out pennants or
something like that, no, we have dolls from the
Augsburger Puppenkiste. Give the
other people from the starting line, okay, okay, so
you've had Augsburg for
exactly six years for the longest time and why does
something like that happen?  over
because I then saw the end of the flagpole for myself
and and after 6
years, we had achieved everything,
so for me at least it felt like
we had achieved everything, so we had an
office that was on the first
floor when I started
Dona Worter Straße  I remember exactly
that it was above a restaurant, yes that
was the office of FC Augsburg
and next to our shops
were the toilets of this
restaurant which were on the ground floor and
so of course every other day
people stood in my office and said, oh
sorry  I thought I wanted to use
the toilet here and all the way
to the new stadium, which was also the
World Cup location, which was for the women's World
Cup
2011, promotion to the Bundesliga, relegation to
the Bundesliga, then I thought what
more do you want to do and
then I did  I also said early on that
I wasn't extending my contract anymore
and wanted to do something else and that
's what happened. I
then switched to the DFL. Can I ask
a personal question in between?
I've always wondered
because that's how her wife is  We have often
mentioned that it is not the
biggest one of the biggest
challenges in
maintaining a family when you work here
because it sounds like a diplomat
moving from country to country and you do
n't have that much
time, so there you have it  In fact,
100% right, that was also
one of the reasons why I
skip the DFL period and come to St
Pauli, why I and my
wife and I left St Pauli in this case
because
in our private environment we said my mother
mother was seriously ill her mother was
seriously ill then now there are
a few more important topics than
football my wife then decided
we are now going back home
to Cologne and that's why I'm at
St Pauli from  If I went on board, I
would have never left
Hamburg again, so it's a great city, a great
club, but since I can't find a better woman
than
the one I've talked about so often,
I somehow need the Te,
I have to
pretend that and that's why  So yes, we're
over, but you have to be capable of suffering
because not only all the moves
because you've
been out and about every weekend for all these
years, yes, that's true, so luckily my wife has it, and
that's the truth in this case too,
my wife
organized the umzüe, that's why she
said at some point, boy, now it's
over, and as I
said, she's been doing it for over 30 years,
yes,
but my wife didn't know any different,
we already got to know each other during
this less successful active time
of mine  and she knew that the
weekends belong to football,
just briefly to the DFL phase because I
think it's interesting that
someone like you not only
knows the club side but also the DFL
side and now today the DFB structures
who D to the DFL
Back then, it was Reinard rauall, the
then chairman of the supervisory board and
then president of Borussia
Dortmund, who asked me if
I could imagine it and I just
wanted to do something different after so many years and
great experiences in
club football  I
can imagine changing the economy, yes, I
've always been
interested in numbers and and and topics, but then I thought
okay, maybe it would be interesting to get on board again
before Seif
then no no with Seifer  se Seif
was there, it was a development at
the
DFL, the DFL was founded for those
who don't know it, it was in
2000 and 2001, so to speak, it came out of the DFB, which is
still the umbrella organization, and there
are 21
state associations  and the DFL are, so to speak,
under the umbrella of the DFB and
this DFL is responsible for and markets
the interests of the 16 proficubs, i.e. the
first and second Bundesliga, and
getting involved in the business management was
interesting. As I
said, they split off back in the
year  2000 2001 December January and
the development was Sand Seifer, he did
a top job for many years.
He was responsible for marketing and
everything outside of sport and I was
responsible for sport, but
after three years I realized that's how it
was  It's not an issue because
the DFL doesn't have any fans and does
n't have any teams, so
sitting somewhere
in the stadium at the weekend during the games and
looking left and right when the goal is scored and
not being allowed to cheer because we  have
to be neutral, that wasn't so good,
it's like a journalist
sitting there in the stadium and always
emotional. I have the impression that
one of the journalists from the BAL has
a fist, but
I can imagine that being difficult, so to speak  To
be responsible for sport at the DFL.
Seen from the outside, the DFL stands for money and
marketing, yes, and of course it's a
job that probably
has its limits where it's difficult
to break out like that. They
hit it 100% because
at my introductory press conference
I have already made myself unpopular with exactly the following sentence:
when I was asked what is the
correctness of your objectives, I said I
would like the DFL to no longer
be perceived as just a marketing association
and that is indeed a
difficult
question but just like mine now
Current task I always try to
make decisions from a sport perspective, so not to ask the question,
how can we
earn the most money now, but rather what
serves the game, what serves the players
and the sport, first and
foremost, that is the
approach  Both then and
now then the last step before today was
then Pauli so you were somehow
then directly by the DFL or was
the date broken in between um so it
felt like a few weeks St Pauli was
actually um great thing and I
still remember that
Press release so we had a
hand in hand, we did
n't have a contract at all back then Joachim
Pavlik and and ok, it's divine that the
two
members of the executive board at the time
signed me up and we sit
together and then the press man came
along and bra quote from them h  you or
you were s pauli you Andreas D I say
yes then I'm like popularly
quotable I have decided on the
economically worst offer
or say that can't be said
so say I'll say it
truthfully as it is if you are like that  If you
talk to people who
have accompanied you throughout this whole time, then
in the end you realize that they are
already very pomerizing, there are
those who say wow, there is
no one who is as brave as him and
he dares to do something and fights
and then there is  Those who say oh,
it's really stubborn sometimes um and
difficult um
if they were allowed to choose now
after all these years now they've
arrived in a different pool in the
DFB as they were best remembered, there
's something that stands out for them
That's how it has been through all the years
and different clubs, so
first of all I would recommend Ms. Gilbert to
only get together with people from the first
group, so please avoid the
second group, yes, that
's what was always important to me
and that's true, they have it good
described VI many like me many
perhaps like me even more it does
n't matter in the end because it
's not the yardstick for my actions whether someone likes me
or not but I'm a
person of conviction and I can say that too
I don't want to say stubborn but rather
convincing or I'm convinced of what
I'm doing, which of course
isn't always right, it's logical, it goes
without saying, but to stand up for things, to straighten my
back,
even to the so-called, that was always
a bit back then, our
Freiburg drive, as well as the establishment
Let's go to V Schimman so that's
always been a pleasure for me.
I have to honestly admit that a
little bit against the
mainstream and to say that let's
see if we can do that with our
on-board resources and with our
topics  I couldn't manage it and
that was a driving force, I'm
quite honest and what
pleased me most in all the stations
to this day was that I was among the people
with whom I was actually the closest to me,
or still are today  I
have an excellent relationship,
even if I still have contact with my
assistant from Freiburg 25 years ago
and on the wards
afterwards, that is a measure for me
that fills me with joy, which you can also
add to that  You have to
comment yourself, you earn
quite well in your job and you
probably had financial freedom after the
first 5 6 7 years in the job to be
able to act in a way that normal people
never have because that's my understanding
Nowadays, managing director at the
football club, you're not quite an
income millionaire, but you're
almost a millionaire, so of course I have
n't worked for any clubs,
played in the Champions League, but
I've earned well, no question about it,
and, I think, but that
was also the deciding factor for me  always
my wife and I, we've always
lived like that, um, as if we were, let's say,
with one income. She also works.
My wife has
always worked at every station
I've been to, and she's
always worked with hers  Girl's name was
applied to work in the pharmacy
because she didn't want to introduce herself as an appendix of
the manager or the managing director
somewhere
and we actually always
kept the standard of living that way, which we said, okay if
it's over in football tomorrow  is
then we don't want to grieve for anything now
and and we don't
need any so they see I
mean people don't see it because
it's a podcast but so I don't have any clothes
no so I haven't
had any designer clothes before no
I have  We don't have a big car, we do
n't have a flashy car or anything like that,
and we also look at it on vacation
and so on, we don't go on
world trips either, so but you could,
what does that mean, with this you could,
I'm already up to it  fell in
with Volker Finke at the time, yes, because he was the one who
lured me to Freiburg with exactly this topic, yes, when
we were sitting together and I wanted to
move to Freiburg and I said yes, and imagine
quality of life, no, you
can, um, you're half  hour in
Elsas you're half an hour in
here in Switzerland and so that's why
you have quality of life so after a
year we're sitting together again I
said, listen Volker, I'm sitting
in the office from 8 in the morning to 8 in the evening when does it start
With the quality of life you
could,
but it's still natural that
you move in an environment that is
very driven by
showing brands, but actually
I wanted to do something else, they believe
that they also think and
feel the same way you do with a KPI Bayern Munich  or
Borussia Dortmund or maybe it would have
worked internationally, would
they have enjoyed it or would they have been
able to assert themselves there at all? I don't know. When it comes to the
question of whether I could have asserted myself there,
I can't
answer the question. I'll say I
had  Topic beay Munich because maybe this
will be a topic again later, I'm afraid when I
see you rolling your eyes,
dear Philipp,
but I have to say I
always have a very, um, very trusting open attitude towards Bayern Munich, for example
I had a direct relationship, I can also report that
everything is gone.
Back in my time in Freiburg, we
also had handshake contracts
with or things were settled with II
höhnes
where we don't want to say the names of players back
then, who signed with Bayern early
and then wanted to stay in Freiburg again
and we settled it back in a few
hours at the time
Karl Hopfer was still in the process and
then shook hands with each other and it
never came out to this day, so there are
topics like that that I had at that time
Incidentally, even as a young manager, I
also looked up to Oli Hönes, like,
wow, so, that has changed
over time, the closer and deeper you
delve into topics,
I say that quite
honestly, um, whether I'm there now
I also couldn't have passed, I don't know,
but it was never my motivation. I never
made my jobwah dependent on the league, never
made it dependent on earnings, but in
fact primarily on people and
the legroom I had at
the stations  uh and uh uh yes from
the job satisfaction no that was
always important to me when it came to the question of
what decision I could make yes
and that was the yardstick for me and
isn't there 1 €o more or less in
the account I can still do that
ask a question and they
said at the beginning they were enthusiastic
and at some point they understood it better
and then perhaps it was no
longer this looking up but then
the prck changed a bit. You can
determine why
they noticed what
they were able to observe  Yes,
I have to say I would perhaps
rather wish that if Ulli Höhes
is here at the table next time
then we'll discuss it in the
round of four. Yes, we don't have to
play a double header but
then I would also give him the opportunity  I do
n't think it would be
honest to say something about what I mean now if I discuss
topics
that he may
not be able to express himself directly at the moment. I
just want to say that what I mean by that
isn't just  on Ulli
Hönes in FC Bayern yes,
but by that I mean a few
issues that are also inherent in the system in
professional football,
which then
lead to perhaps this
enthusiasm or or total
conviction and the love for this
sport in this football  yes, it will be put to a tough
test, for example, yes, but
now I wanted to know exactly
no, no, no, I have to say this
whole development
So 50 + 1 is about co-determination, participation,
namely I always say an industry like
professional football that earns its money with and through the
public, yes, it
needs social acceptance
and if you
no longer have this social acceptance, you wo
n't make any money anymore and then
You will no longer be
able to deal with other topics either and over
the last few years I have actually increasingly
noticed that this
acceptance is dwindling and I
also notice within myself that
I don't want
this hackneyed emotional
alienation  of professional football but there
is something to it, yes, I want to, I
have to go back a long way,
namely to the founding of
the Bundesliga in 1963. In 1963, when the Bundesliga
was founded, there were only 16 Bundesliga clubs for the younger ones,
so those were the
founding members and then they belonged
every club 100% of the member and
the membership fee and the
spectator income yes those were the
decisive income
potential for the respective club
and that has changed yes
with the first exceptions uh D by
breaking through the EVS i.e. that of the
registered club uh through exceptions
from the 50 + 1 rule at the end of the
90s, Wolfsburg Leverkusen say
hello and with that, for the first time,
the
member rights became less valuable, yes, because
other shareholders
came in and displaced member rights
because new shareholders
came in and that  was a first
big step, the second was that when
I remember the topic of
selling stadium names, yes, when I
used to meet up with my buddies,
say you know what on the
weekend we go to the Wedau Stadium
or we go to the Waldstadion in the
Rheinstadion or in  the wildlife park, yes,
every football fan knew where we would meet
if I told him today, so listen,
Peter, you know what, let's meet in the Easy
Credit Stadium, he says yes, where is
that again, no, so also that, the
topic, so this one, that the stadium  The
football fan's living room
suddenly has a name that he didn't even know, it's
difficult but in the end you
know, even in the economy, sales are
a hard currency and if you
have more of it then you have more
design options and if you
have less then that's it  It's more difficult,
so to speak, or would you be willing to
say as a consequence of your 50 + 1 view,
we also allow ourselves to be completely
dependent on
English football and then, at
least in international comparison,
only accept to play the second role, my
dear, dear Philip  I appreciate you
as a successful entrepreneur and a clever
mind, but celebrating
the economic indicator
of sales in this way obviously
ends in a dead end and I would be
happy to explain to you the end of the dead end,
especially with the example of Barcelona. Yes,
Barcelona is one of the
four five in terms of sales  clubs with the highest turnover
in Europe or probably the
world and yet they have an ass
full of debt, yes, I would say the
turnover as such then
all the creative drive is of no use if you do
n't do the right thing with the turnover, I say that's
one aspect
and the second aspect is the
much-quoted rat race, er, it leads to
nothing, which means in concrete terms you ca
n't win a competition with oligarchs, sovereign wealth funds and Chinese conglomerates that all lead to Beijing if you
want to work seriously, economically and sensibly, so I say now
believe that  In all seriousness, someone
Neymar back in his heyday would have
moved to Bayern Munich for 250
million if they could have paid it
then the Qatari would have said
yes, you'll get 300 million from us, which
means you can't win this race
if you have competitors for
them  Money doesn't play a role now, there
was
a fundamental decision last week that
you probably also followed
and it is now possible
to invest in
football clubs, so to speak, and no longer
create any workaround structures for it,
if I'm right or if we're
right  informed and that he
was also reported, but then it was
a
muted decision.
You would say that this is the beginning of
something bigger, so you are talking about
investors getting involved, the
DFL, not the clubs
the DFL on
site with my President Bert
Neuendorf on that Monday morning in the
hotel in
Frankfurt it was the closest possible
decision you
can imagine so briefly explained there are 36
professional clubs of the 36 professional clubs
you need for such serious
decisions that is one
investor entry a so-called two-
thirds majority
and that's the 24 votes
that were at stake. It was voted on secretly,
so it really made you smile.
Everyone was then asked to go into a booth
and then actually ticked it by
hand
on paper
er in 2023,
I have to say that I felt
like a traditionalist, I say with a
wink, um and to answer the question,
um I always
read about DFL business, by the way, I do
n't want to do any investor cruelty,
I said back then and
say it today too, investors are
very welcome, they just have to
stick to the rules of the game and that is
the problem because
you have to make a distinction
between topics that you perhaps
stand for as an entrepreneur, yes the
real economy and that in contrast
to professional football  Because of course
the P&L and the commercial and
tax framework
are of course transferable one-to-one,
no question about it, but the
basic system is different, so if you
do everything right in your
company every day, then that will be
reflected in
more sales  Above all, you'll
probably win more, yes
if you make a good decision,
but if all 18 Bundesliga managers
do everything right every day,
three will still be relegated and, on the other
hand, it's the case that, um, this system is
not primarily professional football,
even if it is  someone else would like to have
the intention to make a profit in the sense
that he says I want to
earn money from it first and foremost. No, that's
exactly where the worlds
collide and why many traditionalists
or nostalgics, among whom I count myself,
say no, professional football has one
other mission, it's not about
making as much money as possible or making profits like in the real economy,
but here it's about a few other
topics and we always have to
keep those apart, but that has nothing
to do with it. I always say that
everyone should be warmly welcomed to investors  Coal
bring everything to Germany, in the
best case scenario, soon to the DFB,
yes, but you have to know that,
unlike in the real economy, you
can't decide on every euro and how the
funds will be used, but then the right ones will come
big investor if you have to be
told what the
money will be used for, yes, but look,
I really defended Mr.hob
against all the resistance from the fan scene
because I not
only consider him an honorable man
but also a great
entrepreneur
and
say that  For me, that's the
investors and entrepreneurs we
need, those with an
altruistic approach who have invested
money in a region over many years and have also
paid tax on what they have already
earned and then afterwards
Incidentally, the company has invested differently than the
factory clubs at Leverkusen and
VW Wolfsbrurg, which
even
have an advantage from their investment through the tax structure, which they
give to the sports-playing subsidiary, so that's
a completely different approach for me and that's
why  I say to answer your question,
yes you see, um dim Hoop
sends greetings, I would like more of them
but of course I have them too, there are
only a limited number of them in
Germany in the league so SAP founder
yes 18 Bundesliga is also limited there are
still but  There aren't even
18 yet, I would say
people who have billions of dollars in
assets and can decide about it on their own. I do
n't know if there
are 18, but it's a crazy
exception and I wanted to point it
out again, so I understood
what you were saying  Nevertheless, my feeling is that
if you continue on your path as an
association or as a league then it will
at least be the case that all the
outstanding players are German
or in general no longer
play in Germany. You have to accept that
or yes, I have to say
about which timeline  Let's talk, we had
developments,
everyone moved to the USA back then in the
70s, yes, Kosmos New York
was there, but I
just want to say that there was the drive, we
always talk about the coal, yes there was
the coal and no, there is  said by that's
B and and Beckenbauer and what they're
all called, they're all going to the USA, these
are the ones now going to Saudi Arabia
or Miami, yes and exactly and I
just wanted to say I want to
describe it on the timeline after that there was
one  Development there are all after
Italy, including our German
national players, and why, because there is
also a Berlusconi Decree in terms of tax law
and heaven knows all,
things were created to
sweeten the income of the professionals a little bit, yes the state
intervened there were different things
Depreciation options so incentives
created why that why everyone went to
Italy so after that there was suddenly
everyone thought yes China is
beautiful but also no yes so they
switched to China yes but luckily that was
just a flash in the pan so now
the Arab world is coming to it like that  I'm
excited to see what we'll talk about in 5
years, but what Philip was
getting at was actually,
I think, at least
in the current active period when you're
not yet at the end of your career, so to speak,
that's what I would say
the top players are playing right now  More like
Pep Guardiola at Man City and
again maybe in Barcelona who are
now trying to do the whole thing differently
but still
as a German fan you would hope
that they might stay in the Bundesliga,
so Florian Wirz is an
example  I'm 18 19 he'll
play a maximum of a few more games here
then he'll definitely be in England
or somewhere else with many others there's
also a Harry Kane transfer that
Bayern can probably do again
but actually the majority of
such people will be here in Germany
Then you won't be seen anymore, yes, but
who knew Florian Wirz 5 years ago
? I would like to take a stand
and I'm
really from the younger generation and I've
always said you're responsible for the
entrepreneurial decision
your house make or buy
yes
especially when I think about the topic of
skilled workers or or
workforce that means make yes educate
yourself or I buy from
you on the job market like that and we have to
find our way and I say we are
in Germany  more on the way to
make yes, we just have to see that
we have, I always have that was my
credo at SC Freiburg when we
started our journey back then,
we have exactly that we have
the millions I
mentioned it at the beginning  invested in the Freiburg
football school and we
said that's the strategic approach,
we can do this rat race and
don't want to take part in it and the
transfer to us as a whole in
Germany, I say, why did
we also have it in Freiburg back then, why does
FC Bayern have to back then?  as an
industry prus why did the best have to
have a better youth department why does
he have to have a better doctor why does
he have to have a better greenkeeper than
us no these are issues we have to
invest in yes and then we will also
have better players and so many
players that we will then
The Arab world can no longer
pay for good training. Last point, I'm putting
together a horror scenario that I sometimes
have to think about. So I also have a
sympathy for your thoughts,
but I think now,
in basketball there's the
NBA  Even the Germans watch
the NBA more than the German Basketball
Bundesliga. Basketball is also
played there and there are somehow people
in the hall, but then there are usually
3,000 and a lot more watching the NBA.
You don't have to worry about
the Premier League, at least now
The NBA can take on this role and everything else
is the Bundesliga more or less
dwarfed into a kind of BBL and
that happens too, but
actually all Germans look at the
Premier League and say that
my Germans play, that
I somehow am a Liverpool fan  and I'm also
a bit of an HSV fan, but actually
I'm a Liverpool fan. That's a scenario in which we wo
n't have that in 10 years. No, no,
I don't think so. I don't know. I don't
have a crystal ball either, but I
can see that for myself  It
may sound old-fashioned now, but
I'll just say that the love and
passion for my own kids, for
my own region, for what's happening around me will
always remain, that is, that's
why I'm also a supporter,
also when it comes to the regional newspapers,
yes and  Simply say this
emotionality, this close bond, yes, to
save the local section in the
newspapers and to say okay, I want to
know what's going on with my bakery around the
corner, yes, and to transfer that, I
want an emotional bond with HSV
to stunk Pauli because  I live in this city and
no Arsenal
London will be able to take it away from me and that's why
I'm convinced that in the end this
will remain a very important point in the bond of nationality, namely
to say that it's mine, but
my city is my club  Now
I think you currently have
a great example with VfB Stuttgart which
supports your thesis, so to speak.
I have rarely met so many people
as in the last few weeks who
suddenly mutate into VFP Stuttgart fans.
It's really crazy and they
identify with it, that's
probably it  also
temporarily at first but still but
still on the subject of identification, which is something that
I find very difficult to imagine and
I also accompanied the national team for years and had to
do with the DFB
is
to regain this identification because that is something
that is even bigger than one
a confrontation with a
football club that is
often passed down through generations, that is an
identification with the country, with
society, with
politics, of course also with the
style of play on the field, but there are
so many things that come together that I think and that
is now likely  Also part of
your new
job I'm wondering how do you want to
do that, of course, there's
a
European Championship here in Germany next year,
that will help, but you still get back
to where you were when it comes to the
atmosphere at a
national team game  the German one
too, I can't give him a serious and
conclusive answer. I can only
express the hope that
of course I wish it would happen that way,
but that's what we're for, we ca
n't make that happen and I always think that those are
the points  What is also important to me is
that it is always the case that
the fan has a very keen sense
and an antenna for it, just like the
citizen in our country knows and
has a feeling for what is happening in politics,
the football fan knows what is happening with the
national team  and and how
things are and I say we
have to get away from these
productions, yes, from these
actions that are primarily focused on marketing, but we
have to go back
to sport, to approachability, to down-to-
earthness, to touchability, so, um,
these are the topics  It's a
process and you won't because there's a
new DFB managing director. Now
everything won't suddenly be fine, yes,
but you have to set an example and I'm
ready for it and I'll say very clearly, yes,
that's what I expect from our
players too. I'm glad that  With Rudi
Föller we have someone who
embodies exactly what the football fan
longs for. Unfortunately there is only one
Rudi Föller. You can tell us now
you have already spent a bit of time there
how it came about that
you were approached  now it
sounds like
you have the first choice right now, so
I don't know if I was the first choice, at least I was
the one who got the contract,
although that was also a snap if
I'm honest, I'm allowed to do that now
say there was a discussion during the whole phase
then or shortly afterwards
about whether this was an afran
whether everyone who should somehow know about it in advance
Bayern RB
Leipzig representatives should be informed how
did you perceive that? Yes, those are
actually mine  both favorite clubs um
in the question I have a special relationship with both of them, yes, um, as is well
known, RB
is quickly explained. RB is for those, um, who
don't know. By the way, it stands for
rasenball,
um, and um, as DFL managing director,
yes, um,
I refused to sign the license twice  I
said that for me it's a classic
circumvention, that doesn't reflect the
spirit of 50 plus 1. I'm sticking
with it, it's still the same um and
um made me unpopular back then
but despite everything I want to do
it again now  It's
important to
say something that RB also did something good
during my time at St Pauli,
we had a big, big campaign,
with a lot of pressure, we
managed to get FC St Pauli in a
game in January in the
second league at the time. RB wasn't in the second league at the time
We were allowed to run into the fascists with the slogan no football
fball and I
then said be careful with my
president divine and said be careful
but we'll do that in the game
that no one expects and where the
contrasts couldn't be greater and
RB has us  sort of selected and
said we actually want to convey this message
together with RB
and I also said even
if we don't like you, yes and if
we are at odds with each other on the issue of co-determination
and participation in a football club,
but there are
a few more important issues  so and
then minslav then and divinely before
the game s pauli RB read out a really
great message against
right-wing yes and that's
why I just want to say there too I
think we
made it clear that we
can take this to another level  is not a
fundamental over all SN it's a matter
but to come back to their start at the DFP,
the RB
managers and his colleague from FC Bayern m
K rumig ran away when they started at the
TFP so I was an advisor
exactly as I said I wanted to explain
why why one of them ran away RB
yes, that stems from my critical attitude at the time
and with Karl Heinz, with whom I
have been friends for many years, but it stems from the fact
that we also crossed paths on the question of 50 + 1 back
then and
he was with, by the way  The meeting that
went down in
German football history was March 22,
2018 when FC St Pauli
landed this surprise cow and we then
secured the majority of votes for 50 plus 1. Renige
wasn't there at all and then
afterward  In retrospect,
I was attacked loudly in a relatively public way
with headlines on the first
page with Kicker R is a populist
and then all of this appeared and then
everyone was very excited with us
not
today I sleep on it once and
I slept on it once and the
next day so everything was there in the media and they
said now what says now
I'll save z romeniger ne like I met
the D I only said one sentence
the next day  and now I say it
today because it's still true today
Karlin Rumenige was a great
striker okay, so when did that
happen, so to speak?
It was somehow on Sport 1
and he called you the king of all the
hypocrites. It was about the World Cup
in Qatar and you also made very
negative or critical comments
and
was a big pronoun for Qatar.
That was the moment when  The
final break came with Bayern. I do
n't even know if there is a final break,
so I don't feel that way now. I
feel like, I've
taken note of the fact that I don't seem to be
Karlin Romendige's preferred candidate
and Oliver Minsl was the DFB
managing director  I heard
from Uli höes, I haven't
heard anything about this. I was
in the stadium a few weeks ago. I was invited
by Aki Watzke to Dortmund against Bayern
in the stadium. I shook Mr. Heiner's hand.
I didn't have the impression
that he would now turn away from me
not the handshake or the handshake
refused so now on a
personal level as far as the current
decision-makers are concerned I do
n't have any now I don't feel any
break now no and um or don't feel that way
um that Ulli is scornful
when he sees his partner and one
important sponsor who donates double-digit
million amounts to the club, that
he publicly protects it when someone
sits in the TV studio like that and is
critical of it. I understand that
and that's why I called him the
ambassador of Qatar, which
makes him a bit of fun, or
whatever  every now and then
exactly yes but but it's fun but it's
fun when you rub shoulders with the
big ones so I'll say be my
dives is always whoever's on the ground
you don't step on them no so W on the
small and weak ones can yes  Everyone no,
that doesn't make any sense, but the
big ones back then said to
take a closer look and have something to be confident about.
I think that would be good for us
I would almost bet that the
differences are actually often
not that big
or do you see it differently? No, that's
actually the case, that's why I say I
also
looked up to Oli Höhes as a young manager and was able to follow
along  Many topics and also with
his fearlessness, with his
clarity and also with his
polarizing way and standing up for
certain topics, live very well on
the issue, but we just have
different opinions here and there, also when it comes to
political views, that's just the way it is,
but that's what matters  Doesn't make me a
worse person per se, or
me, but for someone who does
n't
deal with football on a daily basis and now
hears or reads that, it's of course
a bit of an
industry that doesn't actually exist anymore  So there are these
are
often the same figures over
decades or
years who duel or
fight in a way that you can
now say between anser
and and m Siemens boss or
with politicians maybe but
not anymore  So I think it's
really an entertainment world,
partly also the one that's
bizarre at the same time but also somehow
endearing from the outside, yes,
but I have to point out the
difference again. I just tried it
with Philip in the question
of the real economy
I want to try to bring this out
in your Lufthanser example now,
so
Lufthanser um will
primarily have the ambition to assert itself
in the market environment
and,
in the best case scenario, to achieve a
monopoly position with its competitors
and will then  Of course,
they also behave fairly and cleanly
in the market, but the difference is
Bayern Munich, for example,
a monopoly position is of no use to them because they
also need Darmstadt 98 to
play, which means they have this
competitive situation that we
know from. We can't transfer
it at all  Although they are competitors in the game on
weekend 1530 when there is an attack,
basically yes and that
perhaps also explains this bond that they
have chained themselves to each other or or
bind themselves to each other. Bayern
Munich also needs the little one whether he
likes it or not but there is  There is
n't a really big difference
that you might underestimate and at the
same time always
have to have on your radar, namely the
public - there is hardly any
industry that comments in this way,
but is also determined
by the public, so that's
not what I'm talking about  necessarily only the
fan but also the media
public
and they also have power in
football
or yes
I would say it is actually frightening here and
there if
um ultimately
also fans or the public
perhaps the name of the bus driver from
Bayern Munich  Um, but I don't know the
DAX boss or Lufthanser boss you just mentioned, who is
responsible for tens of billions of dollars, so there's something that's right, there's something that's wrong,
no, I agree with the
question of the
meaning of the real
meaning and the perceived meaning
But I also openly say to them that
I ca
n't judge everything else because I can only
judge football and I can only judge this environment, and despite
everything,
I'm happy and grateful that I
was able to turn my hobby into a career and also  I move in this environment
because if I
now imagine myself as, um, um,
sales manager at the
screw factories, I
probably wouldn't be able to fill it out like that.
Let's talk a little bit about a DFB,
so you've described
that you wanted to think about it again
When the offer first came, you
went to an association that, in terms of
media
perception, was not in a good
position, there was a
tax scandal, there was a
lot of internal friction, so you have the
feeling that everything is
really on a big scale now  There was a mess, um,
that was also a reason to
maybe do it straight, to
want to clean up somehow, to want to help,
or was that he was holding something back,
thought okay, they're on the floor, I really do
n't want to
sit in there anymore, well, I have to  I'm already
saying, um, the task, I mean, we're
now acting
as if the DFB
were nothing, so I'm
proud
of it, maybe that's the wrong
term, but I'm fulfilling it
with the highest degree of satisfaction to have
taken on this task  So
now it's not like, um, that's why I
slept restlessly because I thought
oh, the DFB can do you, no, the
DFB, the German Football Association is
something that has to be said clearly
and and in all the positions that I
had at all the clubs  and also in
the DFL, the DFB and the German
national team, it's a
different league in every respect, yes, and that
's something special, to say it clearly,
because there are
already a few teams, but I do
n't want to say them now  There is only
one team, but uh, because that was certainly
viewed too critically
at the time, that's exactly why the boxing was
overlooked because there are also
several teams in the DFB when I think of
our
women who now also
ensure happiness, sometimes more, sometimes less  As
with the gentlemen, why should I
differentiate between that, um but I have that
I took on the task with full conviction,
um and with particular
attention to this difficult
economic situation, that also
made me say okay, um
it is economically challenging, um
but I'll say  I think that suits
me.
I wasn't able to make the most of it at
any club I was at, but to
say now let's see again whether
we can make the most of these opportunities,
yes in the question
Do you have to turn back a lot of what Oliver biof
has done? Oh, I don't want to
do any Oliver beer brewing now. I
met with him, by the way, because I
too, it was important to me
to understand a few things, yes,
his too in the question
Decision-making processes So I'm
not one of those people who only
know two bad managers, the
predecessor and the successor, but I
wanted to know what he was thinking about when making
certain decisions.
That was
interesting,
I could understand some things well
I
rated it differently, um, but maybe it's a
little bit, we've already
talked about my favorite club,
maybe it's a little bit because of the
different types, yes Oliver, he
also played football in Essen, he's also from Essen, he's from
Essen, but he was
black and white at the patent leather shoe club  eat and
I'm at home with the Rotweiß Essen workers' association,
so that's
perhaps a reason for
different perspectives on what happened
in the past in your
opinion. Now they've done almost completely wrong for 100 days.
I think that the fundamental
problem is that  Um, I
was missing the organizing hand, so
when you look at it, the organizing hand means that
no organizational structure can tolerate that, nor will
any commercial company if
you have new staff at the top all the time,
so if the CEO is
constantly being changed,
no company can and will tolerate that
reflected in bad figures
at the DFP it was now the executive board,
i.e. the president, that changed
exactly exactly and if I now put the CEO
and the president on the same level
then that is a very important point
and I believe and I also see that  A
little bit of my mission
to say that clearly,
um, we have a wide variety of
interests. You have to imagine the DFB structure
or see what it
is, because the DFB is
ultimately organized in so-called five
regional associations that focus on the region
So Northeast, West, South,
Southwest, um, that means, according to
regional perspectives, there are
five
regional associations and underneath them there are 21
state associations, so the regional associations
are divided even more finely into
smaller regions, 21
state associations plus the DFL, which is also part
of this overall structure
and does exist  Different,
um, yes, different motives,
different
desires, especially when it
comes to money, different financial flows
and what I was missing is that too
often and too much, the principle of proportionality and
regionality played a role
in decisions and not
just from above, I'll say from above  We
looked at it from a bird's eye view, what
actually serves football in
its entirety? Everyone has their own
view, one from the north-east, the other
from the south-west, and the other from the
south  It's always
the same player who once
plays for the regional association in the southwest then
maybe has the eagle on his chest
when he plays at the DFB level or
when he wears the brown and white jersey from St
Pauli, it's always the same
player who just has a
different jersey color every now and then  and that
also to understand that W
have a mission here that is not only
subject to a regionality principle but
that in the end
from a different
perspective namely to organize from above
and that is what I mean by that and if there
is no one there who can organize it because
he was just busy with himself
or because, as you rightly said,
because tax issues and other things
were all issues that cost strength and
energy and time, then
the core business
of developing football falls by the
wayside and that has to happen  we are now
moving back to the foreground and that
will be one of my tasks what what
would be a goal so what you
might be able to measure yourself against and that
man I would like to achieve that
in the next two
years what what can there what can  You would
expect that you do
n't know the length of my contract at all, I have it now,
so I can only tell you,
regardless of the
length of the contract, my goal is when I leave
the
DFB, I want to get off the boat and then
I don't want the DFB to call anymore, why
is this contract length such a
big deal?  Secret is not a secret
I can say December 2026 okay
okay but there are more and the and the Euro
is somehow a milestone for you
so doing well there now in terms of
sport my say
preliminary rounds would also be
a problem for you somehow no so that's it
to rule out
in the question that was in the preliminary round
to rule out okay okay okay okay what do
you expect that we will progress
from when is a success for you yes
success is when our hearts fly
so it also means a, let's say
a round of 16 in the Schen gen
France would be okay, so I don't know whether it has to
be against the French,
but I'm just saying
if we come close to the
emotional connection and joy of the
summer fairy tale,
regardless of the placement,
then it was a
success. You can give us the Ken because they
Yes, it's always about getting into sports or something like that, um,
why the sporting success
with the
men's national team is a long time coming, does
it
also have to do with fluctuation? Um,
what
are the reasons for that? Yes, it's in the  Actually, I do
n't think it's easy to describe, I
think that
less than 10 years ago we
were at the top of the throne, so in
2014 we were world champions,
and I think that's like everywhere else,
like every business thinker like us
By the way, we also have the problem in the
youth training centers at the lower
level as well as in the
national team that
at the zenith we ultimately did
n't set the right course,
so that's it, but it's
clear when you're at the top of the mountain
can you just
come down, yes something, for example, the
topic of the
squad,
I'll say I want to
describe it like this, the strategic
squad planning, yes I want to put it like this, so what
we know from the
clubs, yes, so that I if
I if
Especially when I'm in clubs that don't
have much money, I do
n't just have to think about tomorrow but also the
day after tomorrow, which means I
also have to create squad plans that
say today, okay, pass on the Müller.
I don't mean Thomas Müller, but
Müller Meer Schmitz around the time ne the
Müller
is now 30
he can maybe do another two years
the Meyer is already
32 positionally when comes who comes who comes
how for the successor question who
comes from the U21 who comes from the U19
who comes from  17 that means a
strategic
squad planning that has been planned over the years, which is what I've
missed so far in the question, uh, which I
know from the clubs, so
a responsible manager, uh,
he doesn't just look in October, who do
I get now in the winter, but there and  That's
why I have to work a lot harder at the DFB where the
market is even tighter because
I can't sign every player,
so I also have to put a lot more effort into
career planning for,
I'd say, the young hopeful strikers
or game without now too much into it
I
still remember the situation when it was
announced that which
veteran players would no longer
be nominated
something very management-like, i.e.
this
announcement and then there were
the moments again when you thought
maybe you still need them and
in football
the clubs and
consultants often have a huge influence, especially on the national team  For
people who don't deal with it on a daily basis,
that means it's
probably difficult to
independently
plan the squad for a national team because so many
people have a say and also have power
in the
background, so I expect
a good manager and a coach
is nothing else  as a
manager in his area
that he just frees himself up that
he naturally registers external influences
yes, I expect that, I do that
too, but in the end he always has to make
the best decision in the situation,
it's always a competition
for  to make the best decision and
if you are talking about the
topic of advisors or otherwise, I want to
say the first thing: you
always have to take two things into account when putting together a squad.
One is of
course the sporting
situation, the current situation, namely the question of how fit and how
good the person in question is  Players currently,
what added value does it bring to me for
this team but there are also
non-sporting reasons that might
justify a place in the squad by saying that's
why we talk about a
team sport, namely the topic of
togetherness, team spirit
and
who is important for the structure of a
team
so that it has stability and
regardless of whether the person
is on the pitch or
not on the pitch, that means it
's not just that the
best eleven never play, yes in the question and with
Maradonna eleven times or with malonas you wo
n't be able to win a game either, but
that's why  dr ötger already knew that the
mixture makes that one the
second topic consultants is an important
point you are 100%
right I just want to
make my position clear as well. As
DFL
managing director at the time I
put forward one motion or two
motions one of them  was to say if
players you have to imagine the system
if a club
signs a player then
the player signs three contracts so three times
the same contract the same contract like that
and the three
copies are sent to the DFL
are then stamped because that's
the  The decisive and valid
contract is behind it. In the event of a
dispute, no one can say, but
that was the one like that, it's only the one who
has the DFL stamp, the valid
contract is like that and then the three of
the three represented are
sent back, then one gets the
club  the club and one gets it,
the player gets it and I
said that in the future, as DFL
managing director, I will no longer
accept contracts in which a
consultant contract was involved if
it does not have the player's signature on it,
so I want the player to
know what he is doing  for a fee and
what kind of service he got for this
because I simply want that within the
framework of transparency I want
the player to know that the player has to
know what he gave Muren big the
contract has been accepted now,
however, in this specific case
Especially the manager Mr. Nagelzm in
a consulting agency that also advises a lot of
mirrors, which means he has to
be really morally fine,
but so far we haven't observed
that he allows himself to be influenced by it in any way, I have to
say,
so I have the advantage  to
both of them that I have
already gotten to know and appreciate Julian not only on the trip to the USA
but also here and there, even though
Rudi Föller
is primarily the contact person for Julian, but the
complaint I had with him was him,
by the way  small sidestep but
by the way he was already with us c-rainer W during
my time at FC Augsburg
that has to melt in your mouth we
were we were at FC Augsburg in
the second Bundesliga and the coach team
was in the Landesliga Süd Landesliga Süd  Thomas Tuchel and
julan nmann is really great
but since then but I want to say
julian is doing really well so far
I was the first choice please was the
first choice yes
of course
and julan is doing really well and
I also have the impression that he is there
that he is courageous, that he lives out what he expects from his
players and that's why
I'm sure that Philip
will definitely survive the preliminary round, despite your warnings,
that's dangerous for him, so he's
still very young to take this step
Of course he can't have the same influence
as a club coach on a
team because
they hardly see the
team and we all hope that it does
n't happen like that, but if
the German team were eliminated in the preliminary round
then it would be him and that's why  I
think he would be brave, first of all, I
remember him as the national coach
who didn't manage
to get the team past the preliminary round in Germany
and I also think that that's one
reason why many of the top coaches are afraid of
coaching the national team, you see  and uh
we can't use scaredy-cats in this position
but that no, I part of
your view that it places a different
quality or
requirement on the coach
because uh rightly there is less time
to transport uh ideas into the players' heads, that
's completely
right but  A good trainer does
what the situation requires and if I
have less time I just have to
portion things out differently. You are actually
frustrated with associations in general, so
I mean you are a democrat and
actually associations are also something
very democratic but if you have
a lot of them  The DFB has been looking at it for a long time, but
now especially when you look at
FIFA, which may be
awarding tournaments again, it's
a very frustrating
thing for you, so first of all I feel it in our
house at the DFB and we
also have it right now  new
organizational structures have just been
announced in my business area
and I feel a real
joy
in
our company and I really
enjoy it so that I can first
judge what I'm looking at internally  can
and that's why I spent
my strength and energy internally for the first 100 days
and not
with podcasts and and that's why my
first, so to speak, first public
appearance is in the sense that I said
first work inwardly, so I
think I can  allow a judgment,
everything is
great um internationally
I have to say um I'm really
worried um I have to say that so clearly um
I'm a democrat um and that's
why I also accept
the principle of FIFA yes um that um one
country one vote um and um  That's the way it is, um, and
that's what you have to
endure if it happens like that,
which I don't remember. We're now talking about the
fact that the 2034 World Cup will most likely be
awarded to Saudi Arabia
and if we've heard you as a
critic of that  Qatar award then
you can imagine that doesn't excite you
now, yes, I have
n't tried to find accommodation in Riyadh yet, um
please
W, that's
too much for me in every
respect, but
I have to say that it's of course
a process  That's why it bothers me
because what it's
primarily about is putting the players completely
at the back, so what do I mean
by that, this marketing madness,
namely always creating new formats,
generating more and more participants,
and with this easy-to-
understand tactic, everyone
I make an election promise and the
larger the field of participants is and the more
happy I make countries by
getting some of the big cake, which
is basically not a bad thing to say we let a lot more
participate in it  The snacking of the
big FIFA cake, everyone plays D.
Well, it's not a bad thing at first,
but then it becomes something bad
when we
have fixed parameters - we
only have 365 days a year and that in the
end you change the formats to the detriment of the players,
so there is a  The race of the
confederation in the case of UEFA was
over. Yes, FIFA creates other formats,
then there is Club World Cup, but then there is
the number of teams or
players who have to regulate everything. You
just have to look at how
the players are under pressure  In
recent years, these
different formats will continue to
increase and
the cake is actually not only being banked
but also being distributed without
keeping an eye on the players' limits and that is clearly to be condemned.
You probably have to say
something like that too  FIFA works a
bit like a non-plenary assembly,
so to speak, the margins with
votes are of course spread across so many
continents and the
opportunities to
make politics and push through interests there are
huge, which is completely different to the
DFB  Problem that will be very, very
difficult to solve if there
are just so many interests, well,
well, Mr. Infantino already has it
secures uh through elections uh
and uh through concessions and that's where
we are right now with the continents and I
say again I basically have
no problem with it uh and we
also have to get down from the European high horse
and believe that
the music is only here  Um, it sounds like it
can be played to the fullest, so I can also say
okay, which topics, um, can we
tackle together? Basically, I think it's okay, yes, um,
but if the game and the games and
the formats are
in the foreground from these aspects  Then
I welcome that, but unfortunately I do
n't come to the conclusion that this is
primarily about
developing players or things in order to think about it from a sports perspective.
Maybe I can
come back to that again, you
said that
you now have that at the DFB  If
you look at it from the inside, everything is okay. You
can perhaps imagine how
many people,
as a journalist, I sat
across from at the DFB in recent years,
especially presidents who
have left and who
said exactly what I want to get at,
then it's relatively quick  I had to recognize that there
was also a culture problem,
a problem in dealing with each other, who
were disappointed and whose trust
was often abused, so I always got the impression that
regardless of all the
big problems on the field when it came to
finances, which we
might talk about in a little more detail
speak there is a problem namely
a a a lack of an atmosphere
of trust and m want to
go together do you have that in
mind you have that you have that too have
you encountered that too and how can you
change something like that so I do
n't remember now that I  I said
that everything was fine, DFB, yes, so
I can't remember it now, I
said I got an overview,
um, and and I feel a, um, yes,
a positive mood, I
want to put it like this, so, um, but
you're right, I  I also notice that,
um, and recently I've been encouraging
our managers
and saying be braver, yes, um, and
don't look at the wind here beforehand and and
and what's the political situation now
?
The decision is always based on
conviction,
I'll say what's best for us as the
DFB, so um I think you're right too,
the topic of trust plays
a very big role, and
unfortunately you also have to say that there's a lack of trust, and that's also part of the
truth, um  but that I believe that
with Bert Neuendorf, who has
n't been there that long,
with, um, Rudi Föller, although I
now also, um,
nia künsersee, who is the new director
who will also be responsible for the women's department in the future,
that's all  I have
personalities of integrity, uh, who wo
n't make a mess of themselves, who will
push issues forward out of conviction, who will provide a breath of fresh air,
especially when it comes to nia.
I promise myself a lot in this question, uh, and
uh, I also think that uh  It's
a cultural change, there's
no need for a question, but it's
been initiated and I really have to compliment the President
on the question,
the topics, especially when it
comes to the structures, just the the the
the staff Rettig yes also the mus
To have to say against the big ones
then I'll take save now that
actually speaks for the fact that you
want to change something, yes and so I'm
at least ready to change something
because the DFB is really as short of money
as you can read, unfortunately yes  So
we have and I wo
n't reveal any trade secrets here either, we
have a structural deficit of
17.5 million and what does
structural deficit mean quite simply yes
we spend more than we take in yes
so and exactly with this difference and
that  are now issues that we have to get to
grips with together
and that starts on a small scale. Yes, I'll say it
now with a wink.
I also
waived the hotel fees for the first three months, despite the contractual promise, and after the
campus there's no ampus  in Frankfurt
in Frankfurt where I work,
I don't want a medal for that,
but I just want to say that you
can only
credibly advocate for issues of economic
reason if you don't preach
water and drink wine, yes, and that's
why we as managers are all
called upon to do so  Also,
how quickly can you get the DFB back
into the
black? So if we become European champions,
it will be quick, okay, okay,
you actually have a nice
license plate in front of the DFB headquarters for
your slightly smaller car, as you just
emphasized and there  Does it say
managing director on it or has it been
abolished in the meantime? I do
n't know what it was like, but I've
heard and read that too, but I
can tell him that for many
years, and not just since I've been with the DFB, I
haven't had a company car, but rather
one  It's a train card and it has my
name on it. Isn't that
a total culture clash for you or for the players?
You're asking yourself
whether it can even work
to meet someone like you.
I mean a lot of players
from Bayern now  If you are now somehow
used to a lot of money and
maybe live in a different bubble,
you suddenly meet the self-described traditionalist who comes with the train cart, you are taken
seriously at all, so that is what
the players think is the guy
He's from yesterday anyway, he's got the
completely wrong bearings here, um, do
n't you also experience culture shocks like that?
We also had a
conversation with the player wheel,
yes, since everything was about a few basic
topics and I welcomed the player council,
um with a flipchart, I'm still
old world, yes, I don't do a
PowerPoint presentation, but I have their
flipchart and wrote a
warm welcome  Players from VfB
Bösingen SC Neuköln watens scolded the
ex-players in 09, that was the
players' hometown clubs, yes, and
I just said, look there boys and that's where
we all come from, and um I did
n't have the impression that
everyone was somehow together  I said a save
or something like that because, above all, even if
I had Thomas Müller, who
is also a bit of a speaker,
I already negotiated with him when he
was still a small amateur player at FC Bayern and that was really funny
We were negotiating at FC
Augsburg. I wanted to
bring him to Augsburg back then and then,
um, that's why he knew my fable for
power for flip chat and then I
showed him everything that was planned as
I see him and I
really liked it  no and uh
afterwards, at some point now
a year ago or so, I think in
some podcast I also
explained in a big way back then, uh, where he behaved
badly during contract negotiations,
that would have been the right thing at the time,
uh because I said,
I say  Pay attention, Thomas, and now you explain
to me what you can't do,
no, I mean, these are topics where I'm like,
and then I actually
told the speaker what I can't do,
and my advisor told me at the time that
you should never do that, yes  to explain
what you can't do, and that
means I have a history that
other players also
noticed me from a
different time, so I don't have
the impression now that I'm
suffering from a loss of acceptance or a lack of acceptance
then succeeded with the argument, look
where you come from, to get the small
club to waive a bit of salary
or bonuses,
which then easily accepted what was
discussed in flipchut rounds
remains in flipchat
rounds, but what is striking is the
Thomas generation  Müller is of course
one that is more like how should I say it is
passing now and the generations the
descendants that is completely in
society are different and
probably even more difficult
to reach I just had to
think about it now they still have one like
them from the beginning  The conversation
emphasized that they have
social relevance and also
an
influence and talk about something like that with
players without going into too much detail about
this conversation, but can that
still be conveyed because they
are companies, individual companies,
these young players, so I have to say
in the  current current role unfortunately far
too little, I said yes, I
spent my first 100 days more in the organizational structure, we met a few personnel details and one
also left us in the question.
In Rudi Föller, of course, we currently have
someone who is
ideal, not just a counterpart for  for
Julian so for the coach but
also for the team with everything so
that I see myself in a more
reserved role
but um you're right so for
me this whole topic is I want to
put it that way  I had, um, my last
station where I helped out again at
my club where I was active,
Victoria Cologne.
Um, I introduced a common good clause,
which means, um, I said
okay, we're all in the dream job
and I want everyone who
receives the final money  Victoria Cologne is
contractually obliged to spend one hour a
month in a meaningful and
common good-oriented manner
and has
identified three areas of
sustainability, education and social affairs and
then had 20 projects among them,
and that can be a simple mundane
blood donation, but
it can also be a
commitment  be in the old people's home or in the
daycare center, whatever depending
on your taste and I said I
don't control anything, but in the
winter training camp everyone just tells you
what they did and why am
I telling you that because the topic of
raising awareness and the topic too  Education
plays a very crucial role.
I was shocked. We did a
survey among 16 and 17
young people in Victoria
about certain topics that are currently current
and school no
longer prepares them for life. That's our problem,
yes, and then I came up with it  I'm
talking to someone, 17 years old, I say, tell
me, what comes to mind when you think
of ETFs, he looks at me and says yes,
I'm not interested in political parties,
yes, that's education in our
country, and I have to say,
of course they are  Topics that concern
me, if I'm honest, are
really like what Katin is saying right
now, so the generation
of those now in their early 20s is noticeably
different for you than the generation
of Thomas Müller and
30-year-olds
me  I think that there is a
difference, it's clear that everyone has
their own, every generation has something
special and I think
we're not allowed to do that now, I think
what we have to get used to is
this, just like we do with the
trainers
Don't be allowed to play them off against each other,
i.e. laptop and
science against gut feeling and
experience, no, we need both, yes, and the same
with the boys, so to
say Generation Z, they're all
lazy people, they only came with work-life balance,
cheese too, yes, I think so, we  We
have to make the effort
to deal with each individual, yes, that
's our job, and first of all, and
that assumes that I
first know the person in front of me, and
we have to invest more time in saying okay,
what makes him or her tick
I'd like to
take a quick trip to Saudi Arabia
because that's coming soon somehow
and you've already got three hours there from now on. I
think I'll be able to get everything done in the podcast,
say the whole of Saudi Arabia too, by the way,
but what's actually happening
to counter the argument that it
's somehow quite good
to play football in these countries,
why should it only be played in Europe or
South America, why not
there too? There are people there who are
enthusiastic about football then you can do
it  Maybe they want
to bring the structure forward a little bit
through Hal, they
obviously want that too, so there
are also a few arguments from Mr. Hönhis in addition to
the financial arguments that there
may have been a few
arguments W you say okay, certainly
different structures than  in Germany
but you're helping to
open up a certain amount and bring this country forward
now but I'm hearing from you
again you're strongly
against it again, well what does that mean I don't know
where you get it from what you derive that from I
can  I just have to say to you, I just have to
smile because the argument at the
time Qatar was also from her
Hönhis m yes,
we want to bring women's football forward,
so Qatar managed to
not attach any importance to women's football before
then in the
application phase they dealt with the
topic  Women's football to changing rooms because it
was just provided for in the application documents and now
it doesn't play any role anymore, yes and so
I just want to say that one is
the theory and the other is the
litmus test that we will then see
whether something happens  If it were like
you describe it, it would be nice, there's
actually another documentary about the
euros. Now you're actually hitting a sore point at the
end of the conversation.
I have to admit quite frankly,
I watched the documentary
and I
was really worried, really
worried and  they now mean the ones about the
World Cup in Qatar nothing Amazon gen yes
well now let's leave out the angularism because oh
so oh so the thing says it
all or
[laughter]
nothing title yes well someone
actually has foresight
uh uh  Found the name,
no, I have to admit and that's why
I'm there now to
answer the question in this
form in this way there won't be any documentation about
what, so to speak, a right to
a third party who can market it
and decide  Can we make that
out of it? It won't happen that way.
That's also a decision
that we made in our house,
also with Rudi Föller and with one
or the other who is important, and
also with the team.
I talked about offers
Yes, you can't imagine a bad number of millions either.
I won't say anything about it now, but it
was a lucrative, economically good
offer and anyone who just listened and
knows from my explanation of the structural deficit that it
would have been all the more significant, of course
to say so why did they
decide against it, yes against this
form, I don't know, maybe we can
still get the documentary
started, but I also said to those
who sat opposite us who offered us these
many millions in a different way,
um if they  If you
can answer the following question with yes, then we are
partners,
we can as employers and in order to
protect our employees because that's what
they are, um also every scene where we
have the feeling that someone is going to
take out something damaged and if you ca
n't answer the question with yes
Then we can't make a contract with you,
to make that clear, that
means for me I saw the documentary
and I have to say, if I
had been the sports director,
this contract definitely wouldn't have come about like that or it would
n't have been designed like that
Independence Journalists
need independence, I also accept that,
but that's why it's
okay, they're making the point,
Fraubert, but I say we're then faced
with the question of what do we value
more highly: journalistic independence
or protection, er that of the employees,
and I'm in favor of protection  The
employee decided um and said that
I can't allow that um uh in the
end someone might
be damaged um via this way of
publicity and I have nothing
against that although critical so that we do
n't misunderstand each other what we're
doing then that's what we need  then
maybe also critical and
independent journalists but they have to at
least have the feeling that yes, what can
I do with it if I
actually play out this or that scene?
I still have one last
question if you have followed the national team
a lot before major tournaments in the past  Always sure
that Oliver Bierhoff
m played in the training camps. During the
training you will
probably see them on the pitch at some point in the training camp.
So Philip
just asked the question about acceptance,
yes, and I have to be honest about that
at the moment  In the
much-quoted and so-called circle, you
play it like this for those who don't
know it, like five against two, it's a kind of
opening or warm-up thing, no, there have to be
two who are in the middle and are
usually the ones who
are the worst at football
try to get the ball
and play around it,
not only would I have a permanent subscription in the
middle, but I think I would have a
rapid loss of acceptance
that I would like to avoid, thank you very much,
all right, yes, exactly, so
dear Andreas, thank you very much for
coming by  that you could do that
in the constellation like
multiple premieres, I'm sure there
's a lot in it that will interest a lot of people
and will somehow move people,
say so, yes, make that happen, so
now the ball is in your court, thank you
for the invitation  and for the
trust, it was really a
nice experience and I hope we'll see
each other again with ugi,
everything's okay, ciao ciao, everything [
applause]
[music]
Good luck
ه